[Musique]
l'exposition de l'artiste
multidisciplinaire stan lee février au
musée national des beaux arts du québec
s'intéresse à la condition humaine ou
21e siècle mais titre de l'expo en
créole est éloquent fait même vie à
tintin c'est la même crise d'affaires on
peut dans un québécois donc plus ça
change plus c'est pareil
donc c'est pour ça que l'expo s'appelle
comme ça je trouve ça un contexte idéal
d'avant et c'est de cette forme là on
vient une période très difficile
humainement socialement
en tant que société
mais quel changement qui va être fait
les oeuvres de l'artiste aborde
notamment les thèmes de la brutalité
policière de la discrimination et du
raincy si humainement on est tous liés
ça paraît simple mais
malheureusement nous glisse enfin
souvent on est seul ça arrive pozo mais
l'autre c'est aussi une partie de nous
la distorsion de l'image très présente
dans l'oeuvre de stanley février évoque
différentes formes de souffrance je
regarde cette heure-là absolument
combien personnes sont pris comme ça qui
trouve pas de mots comment parler
comment où on a carrément enlever le mot
de prise de parole ou qu'ils se sont
eux-mêmes exclue socialement
donc c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
trier des espaces où ils peuvent parler
pourquoi pas stanley février est le
lauréat du quatrième prix m henjak en
art actuel plusieurs de ses oeuvres
intégreront les collections du musée
national dont celle ci qui rappelle la
tuerie survenue en 1927 à la base
consolidée tout du coup au michigan ce
qui me touche chez stanley c'est un côté
où il n'ya pas de désillusion dans un
message aussi brutale parfois il ya de
l'espoir en fait chez stanley malgré que
ces heures nous ramène à ce qu'ils plus
sombres de la vie humaine ou de la être
heureux cette exposition percutante et
enrichissante sera présenté pendant près
de 20 ans aux mêmes bac ici valérie
cloutier radio canada québec